[Music]
vic and we're back for another episode
of celebrity recipe royale today we're
going to be battling out two celebrity
taco recipes on today's lineup we're
going to have bad buddy but and a team
up from kylie jenner and karuchi trend i
measured out the ingredients as each
recipe stated and i found three taco
lovers to come help me out and determine
which one is the best so which one of
these celebrities has the best taco
let's talk about it first off we have
bad bunnies mahi-mahi tacos first he
hits the pan with a little limoncito
followed with a healthy healthy amount
of butter heating it up until it's nice
and melted then he follows with chunks
of mahi mahi hits that with a little
salt and pepper and flips it when it's a
beautiful golden brown
ooh that's bang bang then he adds some
green peppers to top it off and give it
a little bit more satsang
then next up is the salsita he adds a
small amount of oil not too much
and follows that up with a hit of lime
juice then he adds some salsa and some
mango chunks and stirs it up to combine
all those bang bang flavors next he
warms up his tortilla until we get a
little color and it's time to build we
start with the mahi-mahi hit it with
some cheese be easy because bad buddy
said too much will make you fat some
white sauce
followed by the mango salsa
and there you have it bad bunnies mahi
mahi tacos oh my goodness okay this
doesn't look that bad looks like red
salsa it's pretty hefty this is not my
typical taco
that's really good oh this is fish okay
i can taste a lot of spice that's a
little kick in it it's like a really
nice like slow burn kind of a spice i
was hoping that there was gonna be some
kick to the sauce but it's just cheesy
the flavors are really good this is
really good
it's probably one of the finer fish
tacos i've had actually i'm
a little confused the protein definitely
is the center of attention but i was
hoping that there was going to be more
cheese i feel like i can get a taco like
this from like any random like american
style restaurant it's like not like a
traditional taco it's a good spin man i
like it it's really good i think i could
handle making this at home by myself the
sauce is not my favorite it wants to be
a taco but it's not there based on what
i usually have it's really juicy
all the ingredients kind of complement
themselves it's not too hot it has some
pretty basic ingredients i see some
chili tomato and there's a bit of
sweetness to it which i love i love a
good combination of sweet and savory
this is for people that are trying to
experiment with tacos but for me it's
definitely not something that i'd go for
reminds me of like being in a beach or
something
that's a ghost next we have the kylie
karuchi combo shrimp taco recipe they
season the shrimp with old bay and onion
powder in their words the more the
better mix it all together and set it
aside
then they hit the pan with some olive
oil they throw in some onions tomatoes
and cilantro and mix it up
then they add the shrimp and stir it
around until it's fully cooked
then they get some oil going to the pan
and fry up the tortilla to get a nice
crunch in color now it's time to build
the taco they start with the shrimp mix
followed by some of the fresh salsa some
guac and sprinkle some shredded mexican
cheese to finish it off there you have
it kylie and karuchi's shrimp tacos oh
boy oh my goodness this looks like a
quesadilla i don't know how i feel about
this deep fried tortilla it's like a
patellito i see guac i see a variety of
cheese which is nice okay i like the
crunch i don't know man it's kind of
like dry okay looks like there's some
maybe pico in here it may be good looks
like some taco bell
[Music]
this is really good
this is really good i don't like it nah
it has like a very refreshing and bright
flavor to it i'm not a fan of the
deep fried tortilla i love the crunch i
love the avocado it's nice and fresh
what stands out is like a more of like a
citrus like bright flavor for sure and
the shell is really good
like really good the inside
is good but it's like it feels like
greasier than what it's supposed to be
even though it's fried it's fresh like
the ingredients are just so fresh an
american did this right it tastes really
really like maya bolita made it or
something it's it tastes really homemade
and i love it nah
nah i ain't feeling this i ain't with
this i'd love to get an order of this
for sure
so which one of these celebrities has
the best taco recipe let's find out so
out of the two tacos i'm shocked to say
this but it has to be the second one i
love it because it's just such a bright
nostalgic almost tasting flavor even
though i probably never had anything
like it before but i just love that
extra crunch that it gave and the
flavors were really nice and refreshing
who made it
wow
it's really good i'm extremely shocked i
had a two taco recipe my favorite was
the first one it had a little bit of
kick but it wasn't overpowering it
wasn't dry it seasoned very well i could
eat a few of those who made the first
one bad bunny ah okay i got it out of
the two celebrity tacos my favorite has
to be the second one i love the shrimp i
love the freshness of the avocado i'd
have a couple who made the second taco
wow i okay i was i was not imagining
that from kylie jenner
and there you have it kylie and karuchi
have the best taco recipe
which recipe should we try next let us
know in the comments below bueno ciao
miguel de nofuemo atala prossima
you